Soil protection deserves a
European legislative framework just like
water protection and
air protection so the only ones that's important
it's important for our food
it's important for biodiversity
it's also important for  climate regulation
the deterioration of soils
leads to significant erosion of these
soils but also to a reduction in
quality which leads to a reduction in
the actual production of cessole,
for example in the field
of agriculture
so what we want is  is
indeed a harmonized legislative framework
which makes it possible to
decontaminate which also makes it possible to
better protect to have a more sustainable approach
in relation to the use
of these soils with, for example, a
common agricultural policy much more
respectful of the use of these
soils but  also a
trade policy that will not degrade the
only ones outside the
European Union that is what we voted for
in this report and that is what we
want the commission and the council to
decide in the coming weeks